guys before the video starts i'm doing
going to appeal for syria afghanistan
and ethiopia provinces inshallah people
are literally freezing we will never
live in those conditions help me reach
my target to give them some walls i've
done the seven day free trial of the
qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations what was the system you can
build a habit with the quran by seven
day free trial bonuses not credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys will inshallah i came
across a video which i wanted to share
with you guys i want you guys to watch
it it's so powerful brothers if you if
you can think about it
how does
a
recitation
move somebody so much that they are
crossing the road it catches their
attention
and they cross the road kneel down
and listen and start to cry let's watch
this video and be amazed as much as i
was
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
are you okay mate
are you okay
[Music]
do you like the quran
it makes you
what makes you feel
[Music]
i mean
[Music]
oh my god you're literally making me cry
dude
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the word of god
isn't that amazing brothers and sisters
and you can see that is someone that
subhanallah may be struggling with
whatever it may be subhanallah in life
but allah says
[Music]
him
[Music]
[Music]
brothers and sisters
anytime you hear the kalam of allah you
hear it you read it
whatever it may be you ponder and you
turn back to him just as this woman just
walking down the road and she hears it
your lord is always there for you if you
ever see a distance between you and
allah know
that he has not moved an inch brothers
and sisters allah loves us and he wants
the best for us
turn to him this was a beautiful moment
and we are one life someone can get me
in contact with his sister if we can
find her roll it up to a quran lesson
whatever it may be
while that'd be amazing if anybody knows
who she is how we can get in contact
with her and the person who recorded
this may allah bless him and forgive in
her tawa while it was truly touching and
melted our hearts it's so powerful that
the kalam of allah the quran of allah is
so powerful that it moves people
non-muslims were walking down the road
and people do youtube because there's
thousands of them are they all lying
that their hearts are moved and the
christians try to copy this and by using
the book of psalms it's not the same
because it's not the kind of allah
what a beautiful moment what beautiful
amazing moment may allah gaiden
inshallah may allah grant to the highest
ranks of jannah subpanel imagine her
coming to istanbul just here in the
quran this is how powerful our deen is
and this is what the enemies of islam
fear alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah they don't like this